and in this month's buddy check a report
the FDA is making strides with a pair of
promising breast cancer treatments and
one of them can be given at home yeah
this month we actually have two
treatments to tell you about one of them
is new and just approved by the Food and
Drug Administration but the second one
is already in trials and it's showing
promising results
[Music]
vesko targets her2 positive breast
cancer which accounts for roughly one
fifth of all breast cancers the
medication is used when the cancer is
either in its early stages or has spread
to other parts of the body it could be
administered at home through an
injection under the skin by a qualified
healthcare professional once
chemotherapy is finished
it works by disrupting the signals which
promote the growth of cancer cells
now the other breakthrough in fighting
her2 positive breast cancer is to catnip
or to Kisa it'll be used for those whose
cancers cannot be removed with surgery
or have spread to other parts of the
body including the brain there's three
main groups of breast cancers there's a
hormone sensitive breast cancers the
triple negative breast cancers where
they're insensitive to female hormones
and then the cancers that are her2
positive where they have more expression
of this protein called her T the study
on - catnip published in the New England
Journal of Medicine found that 33% who
took the drug didn't see cancer
progression and after two years the
survival rate was nearly 45% higher for
those who did take the medication versus
those who did not
the oncologist that you saw in that
report Amelia Zelnick did not
participate in the study but she says
any drug therapy for her2 positive
patients will often be in conjunction
with ongoing chemotherapy alright so it
is the 8th of the month and this is the
day that we encourage you to remind your
buddy to do her breast self-exam because
early detection is key to fighting and
treating breast cancer Kirsten so true
such an important reminder Thank You
Denise